Hi, Reggie. Good morning.
Or, good afternoon.
Good afternoon, how are you?
I'm good, yourself?
I'm alright, not too bad.
How's your day so far?
It's getting better. I'm on my way home, so.
Oh, okay. So yeah, it's going to be quick. And I just want to let you know that Andrea will not be able to join us. She called in sick since yesterday. She has fever, so I'll be facilitating this one alone. So yeah, so.
Oh, she not sick. She just didn't want to give me a free trip to build it. I know what it is. I know exactly what it is. Wait till I talk to her.
Okay, I'll get a relay that message to her. But yeah, hopefully she gets better by tomorrow. But I'm not sure if she's going to be here tomorrow. But yeah, so before we start, Reggie, anything in particular, like updates from your side that I need to implement or cascade to Terrence?
The.
I don't think there is anything major. I just want to make sure if you can just convey I've told him, but just make sure he's like checking his tickets and updating his tickets because I know his shift is a little different now. And I know some things can be sporadic and I'm not expecting him to sit there and just be
Mhm.
at the computer the whole time or whatever the case may be. So just to have him make sure he's checking his tickets and updating them accordingly. But outside of that, I don't really have nothing else major for him.
Okay, so yeah, I'm going to do a touch base with him later today. And I'm going to check his tickets as well before I cascade that message. But yeah, he should be on top of everything since he's from the after our schedule. So he has at least ample of time for him to double check.
Okay.
those tickets on this bucket.
Yeah, and so we lost a person on the help desk. So it used to be three people. So Colin left Planet Depots. So with that, with that being said, some of the tickets that, here, I can turn my camera off. I was driving at first, but I just stopped. Because I'm over here talking about my hands and then I'm like, I'm looking at myself. So
Okay.
Um...
With Colin leaving, I'll probably end up giving Terrence more tickets that can be pushed back to a later time and things that are not an emergency since I only have two guys working the day shift now. So we replace Colin. I'll probably push some of the tickets that are not as urgent to Terrence so that way he can address them when he gets in there. So if it's something that like a
Javid.
Mhm.
drive space or some of the foul recoveries that don't need to be done immediately. I'm going to try to push that stuff to him at 3, just since we're down to having two people that covers like the 9 A.m. to 3 when Terrence gets there versus having three people. So his ticket count probably will go up in the meantime.
Oh.
Mhm.
So just to give you guys a heads up since we did, since Colin left.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's the best suggestion that we can allocate some tickets to him. And also, like the non-interventional tickets that doesn't need communication to clients and can be worked on off ours, I think we can just assign that to Terrence as well.
Okay, yep, I was thinking the same thing. And then like some of the new hires and things like that, like the AMI people that are contractors that he doesn't have to do a machine setup or something like that. They're just on the ABD. Probably give him more of those two so that way he can do them in the nighttime when things aren't that busy.
Okay, yeah. But do you have a dispatch coordinator for those tickets to be assigned or he can just get it straight up from the board?
Yeah.
He can get it straight off of the board and then most of the time I'll assign them to him. If it's things that come in earlier that can be addressed later, I'll just assign it. So probably just have to give him a note to make sure he checks to see what's assigned to him when he first comes in at 3 or whatever. So he can kind of see whatever's new. And then most of the time when I do assign them to him, I leave it as new.
Mhm.
I don't change it to schedule just so he can see that the status is red. So that way when he does see it, he'll know that it's something new. It's not something that he had previously.
Okay, yeah, I'm going to talk to him in regards to that later. Yeah, so I'm sharing my screen, so this is it.
The.
Yeah, I see it.
Okay, so let's start. So basically, this is not to you anymore. Agenda check-ins, highlights, action tracker, performance, KPI, way forward, and recap. So basically highlights first, attendance. In terms of attendance, Terrence demonstrated strong reliability.
Gotcha.
by maintaining the perfect attendance during the month of May. And also in regards to appreciation, Terrence demonstrated a positive outlook by expressing gratitude towards the organization, which is you guys, emphasizing the strong support and his satisfaction to the after hour schedule. So basically, he enjoys his schedule right now.
Okay.
So he doesn't have any complaints and I think it's he this time management that he have, he has at the household and then going here at the office doesn't have any problems. And he mentioned that he also has time now to do going to the gym, having workouts. So.
Yeah, he likes his schedule right now, so...
Okay, that's good.
Okay.
All right, so performance analysis. This is the only thing that I captured for him for this month, ticket resolution, ticket trend. So as you can see from week one, it's 25, week 232, week 322, week 420. And the target percentage that we have for resolution rate is 80%. So he's meeting the target.
which is great. But I just want to ask Reggie, since I'm new to Terrence, I'm handling Terrence, is there anything in particular that we need to measure aside from this and also the CSAT?
Nope, that's it. So with us, we kind of don't use the stats or we do use the CSAT, but as far as everything else, we're more so focused on like just giving the white glove service, especially with all of our people being internal. So we don't really have like a high standard of
metrics or things that we follow. We just want people to have a good experience when reaching out to the Helpdesk. And then that's kind of like it. So we don't really measure none of the normal measurements that or metrics that a Helpdesk has because of the line of business that we in. And you probably seen that in some of Terrence's tickets where he's reaching out to people and people are not responding and things of that nature. So we don't even
Mhm.
hold that against people because we know depending on the person in the position, they might not be in the office or they might not be responding to teams every day because of their work schedule. So like we have like a couple of different shifts. We got people that work on the weekends. We got people that just work regular 9 to 5s and then we have like some off hours people. So with our people being
Mmh.
spread out all over and whatever their positions is, it's kind of hard to say like the metrics of call resolution and the first call resolution because we may have a person call to ask for help, but then they're going to do a job and they might be on that job for three or four days to the point where we're really not able to contact them or they're not responding to us in that nature. So we've been working with
Management and things on our end just to say, hey, you know, it's okay if you're on a job, but at least tell us because you're calling and telling us that you need help. But then when we're reaching out to you, you're not responding. So just to give you a little insight. So the numbers are fine. So like as far as closing tickets and getting the 80%, that's definitely a plus because I've
Mhm.
Yeah.
I've seen it lower and it's not because of the technician, it's because the person who they're reaching out to is just not responding. So that's actually good.
Okay, that's nice. And before anything else, is there anything that we can, like, add up to his skill set? Like, do you have some trainings in mind that we can train him for?
Kam.
I think he did the Azure one already. I think, yeah, he did that one already. I don't think we have anything else pending right now for the rest of the team. I think that was the only one we had. As far as internal training, like
Like...
The certification for Azure.
you know, we'll support anything that he wants to learn or is potentially as far as his growth career. If it's something that he wants to go for it or if it's something that he wants to learn or something he's interested in, then he can just let us know or you can let us know and then we'll happily support him doing it. And if it's something that we actually have
at Planet Depos, we don't mind giving him access to allow him to do it, to be able to get the experience or, you know, to get some insight.
Mmh.
Yeah, because the reason why I'm asking you this is I don't want you guys to feel that he's just sitting there or stagnant in terms of like, there's a lot of capacity for him to, you know, exert an effort or help you guys in terms of dealing with the tickets. But I understand now because
the ticket closure is the only thing that we are measuring at the moment for him. The only important thing right now, based on my understanding of the information that you have provided, is like, as long as all the tickets has been handled on a timely manner and it was resolved in a timely manner, you're okay with it.
Right.
Yep. And if it's not, even if it's not closed, as long as there's some updates, we can see, hey, he reached out to the person, the person didn't respond or whatever the case may be. As long as we can see that, or I can see that I'm perfectly fine. So we try to reach out and you know, the standard thing is we, I tell them, if you reach out to somebody three times and they don't respond, you can let me know.
Okay.
And then most of the time I'll tell them to close the ticket. Sometimes I'll reach out to the supervisor just to say, hey, we were reaching out to this person. They haven't responded to us. But most of the time I tell them, don't worry about it. Just go ahead and close it. I'll deal with it on the back end. If somebody comes back and say, oh, you closed my ticket and whatever the case may be. But it's like, you know, as long as I can see three times that they've reached out to the person,
I don't care about the rest of it because it's kind of like we can't, you can't call 911 for help. And then when they get there, you say, no, not today. So that's my motto. I tell them all like, you can't call for help. And then when help get there, you say, oh no, I'm not ready yet. Like it don't work like that. So.
Mm.
Yeah.
Stop.
Yeah, so yeah, okay. I'll take note of that. And what else do I need to tell you? I think that's it. So next slide. Okay, so way forward. So this is.
my project for him, collect top call drivers that Terrence is having difficulties and conduct training to maximize utilization. So I'm going to ask him this information, like if he can provide me like top five or top 10 top call drivers that you guys are handling on a daily basis. And then I'm going to ask him.
Okay.
what kind of incident or issues does he have problems with or difficulties resolving it on a timely manner or causing some delays. And then from there, maybe I can give you an updates with this and then I can.
add some skill set to him. So there's no extra charge or anything. It's just being proactive and provide some trainings for him internally so that we can maximize his, again, capacity and also his technical abilities. So yeah. And small projects. So is there any...
Good.
Okay.
tasks that we can provide him like small projects or maintenance for a server or for a specific machine for some users, something like that, that we can or that he can do during after hours.
I think.
I think he's doing, we got him a lot of little tickets now that he's doing auditing different applications and he's auditing Office 365. So I think long as he's doing those, I think that's all we have for now. I think we, when we normally do those like quarterly tasks. So I think his quarterly task was
Yeah.
a couple of audits that he can do throughout the day where he doesn't need any user interaction or intervention. So just cleaning out Office 365, you know, checking licenses, a couple of other ones I can't remember. I think some of our other applications that we use, so he's checking those and doing those. So I think.
Mmh.
That's kind of like all we have right now. I don't think we have anything else pending.
So, so he's he's he's doing like um internal audit or...
Yeah, so he's doing like our asset management one. I think he's on Office 365. And I think it's another one he's doing too. I can't remember what it was. I'm like, I'm like I said, I'm sitting in the go ahead.
Okay.
Mhm.
Does he?
Yeah, does he do health checks for the systems that you guys have, like system checks, health checks?
Nah, we normally do those through RMM or whatever. So we normally do that. I don't think we even set up a policy for it to be audited right now to run those, but I think it does check the health of the machines and then it establishes tickets. So I think outside of that, that's kind of like all we're doing now. I don't think we actually
RMM.
set up a health check for machines, even though RMM does it. But I think even now with the problem of getting equipment, I don't know if you guys are experiencing now on your end, but with the backlogs and all that stuff with the RAM and AI becoming so big, I kind of feel like we're kind of slow walking that process to try to
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
just keep everybody together, making sure the new people are good, and then like rolling out machines as people need them versus just proactively replacing machines that aren't really causing problems right now.
Okay. All right. So, yeah, I'm going to discuss all those things to Terrence later. And lastly, Reggie, ITBD holiday on June 12th, which is Independence Day. So do you need Terrence on that day? It's A Friday, next Friday.
Oh, nope. If you could just send me an email, I can put it on the calendar so that we that way we know he's off. But outside of that, I think we're good.
Okay, I'll take note of that. And lastly, Reggie, I just want to ask as well, do you want this service called monthly still, or we can do bi-monthly, like after a month?
All right.
Uh, I think we could do, we could do.
It depends because I value your time, yeah.
We can do bi-monthly. I feel like bi-monthly would be fine. And if anything does pop up, I can reach out to you all in the chat or something like that if we need to set up something before the next meeting.
Mhm.
Okay, I'll take note of that. All right, so yeah, this is the one that you're talking about. Build it Live 2026.
Yeah, see, that's why Andy got sick on me because she didn't want to give me a free ticket. I know, see.
Did she promise you anything last time you talked?
Nah, nah, she didn't. She sent me the, I actually did one of the interviews last year. So she sent me the recording of me doing the interview. So then I was waiting for this meeting so I can be like, oh, so since I did the interview and I did so well, I know you're just going to give me a free ticket, but she ran off and got sick and now she didn't want to give me a free ticket. So yeah.
Yeah.
Don't worry, this is recorded. I'm gonna show this to her.
Yes, make sure she sees it. I'm like, Andy, owe me a ticket, but I hope you feel better.
The.
Okay.
All right, okay, so I think that's it. So any questions or feedbacks for Terrence?
Nope, I think he's doing a good job. Tell him to keep up the good work. I don't have anything bad to say about him. I haven't heard anybody say anything bad about him. As long as he's updating his tickets and being responsive like he is, we don't have any issues. Everything is great.
Okay. All right. Thank you so much for your time, Reggie, and enjoy the rest of your day.
No problems. All right, you do the same. All right, bye-bye.
Bye.